have you ever in any relationship with
Pete Davidson oh yeah yeah Pete is I've
known Pete since he was like 15 not
super well right but always seeing him
always told him hey man you're a funny
kid you're a good kid right and I still
feel that way he's a good kid who just
happens to be great at getting [ __ ] why
y'all got a problem with this man all
time for sure all time yo yeah who
dislikes this guy you're jealous no it's
crazy it's like when you think of his
Hit List it's like
it's like Leonardo DiCaprio it's like
Pete Davidson I mean yeah but Leonardo
DiCaprio no disrespected Pete it's
really really rich did Titanic it's a
much more beautiful looking than Pete
Davidson no disrespect yeah sure I'm not
even oh yeah this guy's like been a hard
throw since he was 17. yeah oh yeah sure
I'll [ __ ] Leonardo Caprio why not but
I'm not I'm saying Leonardo DiCaprio I
remember him slaying with women
after Titanic the highest grossing movie
of all time where he is the iconic
heartthrob quintessential everyone yeah
he better be getting [ __ ] after that
yeah he is just out here people Peach is
the guy for medicine guy on SNL looking
ganglers terrible tattoos yeah I just
asked some funny ass rants but like no I
don't know girls that will look at a
rant and be like I gotta [ __ ] the guy
doing the rant on the weekend and like
we're talking like Kim Kardashian
uh Ariana Grande like yeah yeah it's
like it's the greatest list in history
quite possibly now there's somebody else
I'm I mean let's see Jeter had it jeters
is nuts Pete Davidson is arguably as
good as Jeter and that's crazy yeah
crazy it's crazy man he must he must be
a real cocksman that guy yeah dude God
bless him I mean just something